Stall point. The stall point is one of those things — it's the second most common cause of accidents in paragliding: preventing the wing from flying forward, entering a thermal or flying inside it, simply braking too much, and you've come too close to that stall speed without noticing, and then you stall the wing unintentionally.
At low altitude that would of course be fatal, and at high altitude you simply have to have played the whole thing through before and know it.
We've also discussed it many times on the training slope. The stall point is now the point — you know the whole thing — where you pull the brakes, pull them very deep, until the wing actually no longer flies forward but first goes into deep stall and then keeps going into backward flight.
And afterwards it could even result in a full stall.
Deep stall is this transition, and now once the wing is in deep stall it simply needs a very clear command: should it go forward again or should it go backwards?
The stall point announces itself in various ways, of course. We can feel it through the brake — through the pressure: the deeper we pull the brake, the stronger the pressure gets.
Once we've reached the stall point, the pressure drops.
That strong pressure we had down there suddenly disappears — like a shot from a pistol. You suddenly have no pressure at all, bang, and you have to immediately go up with your hands.
Or you can observe the whole thing visually — that means if you look at the wing, it's nicely taut at first; the harder you pull the brake, the closer we come to the stall point.
Once we've reached it, the wing no longer flies forward but is in deep stall.
But the span of the wing from wingtip to wingtip is still there — that is, the span is still preserved — but now the air mass pushes from below onto the wing; that means you can see how the undersurface bulges upward, makes real bulges. That's a sign you've reached the stall point.
And these two factors have to be taken somewhat independently of each other.
It can be that you see it visually on the wing first and only feel it a second later
on the brake — which could already be a big problem, for example.
Or the other way around: you feel it first on the brake before you can perceive it on the wing.
Those are the two factors.
And there you simply have to work very, very sensitively.
When we train this — in summer we actually only do it over water, as part of safety training — it could also be that we do it in winter, with enough snow as a buffer on the ground.
And then it would be important to me that you try to do it very, very compactly.
Be concentrated, very attentive, and when in doubt — and this always applies to this manoeuvre — when in doubt the hands simply go up.
If you think, well I'm actually pretty close now, or for me it's already too close, hands up.
We lose nothing by doing that.
I'll then tell you, yes, there was still a little bit missing.
Then you can store that away.
Yes, OK, a little bit was still missing.
So to find the stall point, we have to pull both brakes relatively far down.
And so we have a good feel for it, I'd also recommend wrapping the brake half a turn.
Possibly the steering travel is so long — especially over the lake mostly, in such calm air — that it might even be that we have to wrap a second time.
But for now let's just take that one half wrap.
You look at the wing and pull the brakes very slowly and symmetrically further down.
Also notice how this steering pressure increases.
So already in the first 20, 30 centimetres, pull slowly, keep pulling, but slowly — watch the wing, observe it.
And then you notice, oh, the steering pressure is getting noticeably harder.
Oh, now quite hard.
And suddenly, bang, zack — you have to go up.
You've reached the stall point.
If you doze off at the stall point and persist in that position, it goes into the stall — that is, into the flyback.
And of course that's to be avoided.
We don't want that.
We only want to feel out this stall point.
Where is it roughly?
Is it here?
It can be at different places.
Above all when we're flying thermals, it can also be up there.
What's always important is: bang, hands up.
If you have the feeling I'm there, bang, hands up.
As I said, when in doubt: hands up.
And watch the wing while doing it.
That means maybe you'll have been able to spot it visually already.
Ah, OK, I don't yet feel any release on the brake.
But I see it visually.
Down there on the wing the undersurface is bulging out — bang, hands up, always brisk up.
What can we do if we're stuck in deep stall?
For example, a B-stall exited too slowly — I once had it with a very, very light young woman.
She exited the B-stall very slowly, got stuck in deep stall.
That means the hands are already up.
We can move forward to the A-risers.
We pull the A-risers and let them back up.
That would be the exit for deep stall.
So really pull,
and release again.
And then the wing should at the very latest start flying again.